grâce aux dindons renforcer votre coupe
rené tu vas appelé me fait rire hervé
thiard et du lobby des valeurs
essentielles de la fidélité vous et la
finlande sans cette ambiance en avait
une à ma famille
l'engagement avait wes de mes rides
le pragmatisme
si je suis reprends mon mari je suis à
vous c'est fou j'ai une chance au
conditionnel mais c'est
l'incompréhension vous dise à icloud z
paf en bourse sauf challenger le veuf
peut recommencer dans des clubs qui
finit la clairvoyance mari ont investi
les maris des femmes qui ne plaît sont
toujours des imbéciles en pâtit il y
avait monsieur bah tout y est vous
retrouver les vraies valeurs du couple
dans
le d'intérêt
[Musique]